first up he's the Democratic senator
from Hawaii a chief deputy whip of the
Senate Democratic caucus Brian Schatz
[Applause]
you're here on a very slow news day my
goodness yeah so you look you're a
senator I've got to ask you right off
the bat what do you think about us going
into Syria like this
sure well first of all we don't exactly
know what the operation is but the first
thing we need to be concerned about is
we're at about 2,000 American
servicemembers so we pray for their
safety the second question that I have
and I don't think we know the answer to
that is that the way it was phrased was
that this may be an open-ended
commitment in which case they have to
come to the Congress and get a new
authorization of the use of military
force I said no it is just an air war
though right right but they're talking
about the willingness to sustain this
over time and if they do that there is
no way that this is authorized by the
2001 AUMF that was designed to go after
al Qaeda and affiliated groups and
Bashar al Assad bad guy awful dictator
murder but it's not authorized until you
go to the Congress and the last thing
I'll say is that you know we all saw
those images of those kids being gassed
and I think it touches all of us but the
thing that the American government ought
to do is what we've always done which is
take refugees in we
I was on there sweating well we should
take in as many as we possibly can look
these are children how many is that
Germany took a million well listen I'm
not sure how many we need to be taking
in but we I was on the the Syria Jordan
border this is Atari a refugee camp and
these are children these are families
they are no threat to America what is a
threat to America is the idea that we
reject these people because they don't
look like us so if we're committed to
taking care of these children a military
operation may be necessary tonight but
our commitment to refugees is what we
need to focus on if you are running for
president would you say that was one of
our priorities to worry about refugees I
think we should worry about refugees I'm
not rude I'm saying it's a priority I
mean I'm talking about the people in
America who are thinking well we have
other issues and other problems well I
think we can walk and chew gum at the
same time I really think that at some
point one of the things that people are
really frustrated with Democrats about I
think is that you know we have pollsters
come to us and tell us how in what rank
order to talk about things and if
refugees poll number 11 then we stop
talking about it and I think as a matter
of principle what about Russia well and
I've heard a lot of Democrats say well
people really aren't concerned about
Russia that much and therefore I don't
think Democrats prosecute the issue so
much and I don't know if you can't if
you can't make treason an issue I don't
know why you're even a party well I
agree with you on that I think that
listen there's no way when you pull
something and you ask a person whether
they care about their own health care or
their own tax situation or their ability
to for college whether you know Russia
is not going to penetrate that top two
or three but that doesn't matter what
matters is it isn't your job to make it
well I I'm agreeing with you I think we
have to be the party of the rule of law
because the other party's not the rule
of law is not the party of the rule of
law and I think it's really important
for us to just occasionally do something
because it's right even though right now
it doesn't pull sort of hi on our little
priority list
one of the things that happen I think in
the last election is Democrats
paint-by-numbers they get told what to
say and they say it in the fashion that
they're told to say it and in the order
that they're told to say it and I think
what people were frustrated
by in terms of democratic leadership is
that we don't look like we're working
from our gut and I think the operation
of law and the rule of law is something
we ought to run on we also have to run
against their attempts to repeal health
care we also have to run against their
terrible tax cut which is the only major
tax cut in American history that's still
unpopular and we also have to run on
making college more affordable but that
doesn't mean we can't prosecute the case
around the rule of law so if this
bombing campaign in Syria another
president I just saw he spoke only about
half hour ago said it's gonna go on in a
more sustained level than the one he did
before which is only one day is there a
time when you would say times up on this
I think he gets a day or two to run a
couple of day campaign and after that he
has to come to the Congress and ask for
an authorization of the use of military
force there is no scenario either
legally or in terms of our geopolitics
under which this should be authorized by
the 2001 AUMF we've got to go back to
the Congress we got to get back to the
role that we used to play in terms of
prosecuting foreign policy one thing
that he said which I liked which I'm
sure was written for him was that the
the what was that he was going to use
every instrument of American power
including diplomacy and I think that to
the extent that we have a theory of the
case in the Middle East it has to
include staffing up the State Department
and understanding that we are strongest
when we use our diplomatic power okay I
know that you were on the committee this
week that was interviewing Mark
Zuckerberg yeah how did you find him see
me
I looked like a real nerd haha is that I
thought you did fine I think there's
kind of two ways to look at this first
of all they did they did not recognize
that their platform was used by a
foreign government to kind of hijack at
least a portion of our election but
that's kind of to me separate and apart
from the broader question around
Facebook Google and these tech companies
which are so ubiquitous and so large
that we really have to think about what
kind of federal regulation that there's
going to be for these tech companies
I'll give you an example Google and
Facebook consume about 61% of all online
ad revenue and that number goes up and
up and up and everybody uses all of
these tech platforms whether it's
aviation or shipping or cars or telecom
we all have a separate statute to govern
how they operate these guys are
operating in the wild wild west and that
just can't continue
well I'm got to my next question can it
continue what what is the Congress going
to do because it looked to me like you
talked to him he gave you a lot of the
answers that you wanted to hear and I
don't know what's gonna happen next but
you're right not only is are they
immediate either' the biggest media
company right by far well I think what
we ought to do is two things first what
what the European Union does is give
individual consumers our right to their
own data to control their own data and I
think all tech platforms ought to adopt
the EU approach to that to basically say
if you're gonna monetize my data I have
the ability to see what you have on me
and I have the ability to delete it
because it's my data it's my information
and it's a right to control the data
that people are using about you the
second concept that I think is really
interesting and we're pursuing it right
now is the idea of an information
fiduciary so just like a financial
adviser is supposed to put themselves in
your shoes I think tech companies ought
to be able to put ought to be required
to put themselves in your shoes when
they're controlling your data they are
monetizing our data they are watching
you online they're making lots of money
I think it is incumbent on them to
utilize that data in a way that takes
care of our privacy that is not
something they're gonna do voluntarily
that's something we have to pass a law
for all right senator thank you so much
for yours
hospitality I spent every New Year's
there I wouldn't miss it for the world
thank you